See,
I'm going to see your
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
the fifth chapter, the chapter of the
chapter of
vigilance of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
of vigilance of Allah's observation
authored by of
Abu Zak
He says,
[Silence]
here he mentions in the 64th consecutive
narration it's actually the fifth
narration in the chapter
he says on the authority of Abi Hurra
Abu Hurra's first name is
Abdman Ib
and he is from where
doi
and he became Muslim which year
right so that gives him about four years
and change with the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam and he passed
away which year?
59. Very good. Oh,
oh my goodness. Pretty soon I'm going to
have to sit there and you sit up here.
And so
Abu used to say
he knew narrations
from the prophet Sam
that the political climate did not
permit him to narrate publicly.
prophecies
of things that would come in the future.
One of those was
the im
the chaos that would ensue and the
evil that would crop up in the Muslim
empire at the time
around the year 60 after Hijra.
And this is
the around the time when Ib Abdul Malik
and
his governors
took over in the year 60 after Hijra. He
used to say, "Oh Allah, I seek refuge in
you
from the leadership of the fools
and
what comes after the 60th year."
That's what he used to say. He couldn't
say
exactly. We have those other narrations
where the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam mention
that liars would would appear and
that murders murderers
would assume the throne or assume
leadership positions over portions of
the Muslim empire at the time. The most
critical place
in all of the Muslim empire
at the time was
because that was the front line. That
was where the new Muslims were coming
into Islam, new region regions. Islam
was expanding at a breakneck speed.
And so whoever was in a position of
power in Iraq
was in a position to do a lot of good or
wreak absolute and total havoc.
Absolute and total havoc. Why?
Well, not just because
that is where the Muslim Empire is
expanding to, but also
because of the point that all of these
new Muslims are coming into Islam at
that in those regions and they still
have not learned proper Islam. be very
easy to control,
very easy to
turn against the Muslim in the older
regions of Islam such as Medina and
Mecca and the Arab Peninsula and these
places. And that is exactly what
happened.
Yui
was appointed governor in Iraq and
he proceeded to put to death thousands
of
Muslim men of the greatest scholars
and hundreds of companions.
All the alan hundreds
and this all ensued what year? 60 after
hijah. So he used to make dua. Oh Allah
I seek refuge in you from the leadership
of fools
and
the year 60 and what follows. And so it
said that Allah accepted his dua and
took him back in the year 59 after
Hijra, one year before all of that
chaos.
narrates that the prophet Sam
said
indeed Allah the most high does have a
jealousy
and the jealousy
u of Allah is triggered
when a person
does what Allah has prohibited upon him.
And what's meant here by jealousy is not
a jealousy that comes from a person who
is insecure or what is meant here as an
mentions is alfa.
Anifa is
a kind of
jealousy that
comes with a level of pride
and comes with a level of
a level of
a level of loyalty. Y that if a person
is very loyal and takes great pride in
himself or a thing and then someone
transgresses
against that this is
something that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
will seek retribution
for. Now what this means and the reason
we have this narration here in this
chapter is that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is not one to be overlooked or
ignored. He is to be feared. All of us
disobys Allah and Allah is the most
merciful.
He is so incredibly merciful that it is
unimaginable the amounts of mercy and
pardon and forgiveness that he subhanahu
wa ta'ala has for those who turn to him.
However,
it is never to be forgotten that he is
well.
He is well subhanahua
does have anger. He does seek
retribution.
He subhanahu wa ta'ala is not to be is
not to be slept on. Meaning that a
person falls into
falls into a place of
a place of complacency
where no I'm fine no matter what I do.
you know Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
would never do this to me or that to me
in this way when a person disobys Allah
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is the most
loyal there is no one more loyal than
Allah to those who are loyal to he
subhanahu wa'ta'ala however if a person
transgresses the boundaries of Allah
They are never to feel assured
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will not
seek retribution.
Whether it is a big deal in their mind
or not a big deal in their mind.
Disobedience of Allah is something that
is not to be looked at with respect to
the sin itself. A person doesn't just
see it as well that's not a big deal
looking at the sin itself rather they
are to look at what the sin represents
what does it represent it represents
disobedience of Allah almighty so we
don't look at the sin rather we look at
who the sin is against subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
and so Allah forgives and he is the all
forgiving he is the most merciful he is
the vast past in pardon. However, he as
well is one who becomes angry, one who
seeks retribution,
one who avenges subhanahu wa ta'ala, one
who has every right to bring to to bring
to justice whom he chooses, when he
chooses, how he chooses.
What is the prerequisite
that a person is to have in order to
in order to obtain the forgiveness of
Allah?
It is
it is something that begins with an
attitude
with an attitude. What is that attitude?
And Muslim Abu narrates that the prophet
sallall.aii Wasallam said
Here
[Silence]
he says that
a man would
disobey Allah, would commit a sin,
and then he turned to Allah and said,
"Oh Allah,
I have sinned. Please forgive me." And
Allah responds with, "My servant has
acknowledged and knows and is aware
that he has a Lord,
a God
who
may punish for a sin and also has the
capacity to forgive that sin. I forgive
my servant." Look at the attitude here.
If a person sins and just has Allah is
forgiving but does not have that
consciousness, that conviction that
Allah is watching him and could seek
retribution at any moment and has every
right to do so. If a person becomes as
they say complacent to the point where
they have no more fear of Allah
then this is greater than the sin a
person may have committed. That attitude
of a
Allah says, "Have they
become complacent with respect to the
retribution of Allah. For indeed one
does not overlook and is not complacent
with respect to the retribution of Allah
except for the truly truly loser people.
Those who have lost everything in this
life and the hereafter. The first
mistake is to think that Allah will not
punish. He will. He can. He may. He
does.
However, we seek his forgiveness. But we
always have that hope and fear. And this
is the point of this narration in this
chapter, the chapter of vigilance
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Vigilance
of his observation, vigilance of his
retribution.
for
subhanahua.
[Silence]
You're welcome.